elles nous apportent aussi l'oxygène que nous respirons,
mais les plantes sont aussi les sources
d'ingrédients actifs biologiquement importants
que nous devrions étudier avec une grande attention,
parce que les sociétés humaines, à travers les millénaires,
ont développé des connaissances importantes,
des us et coutumes,
et d'importantes ressources médicinales basées sur les plantes.
Voici quelques données :
1,4% de la surface émergée terrestre
abrite 40% des espèces de végétaux supérieurs,
35% des espèces de vertébrés,
et ce 1,4%
représente les 25 lieux les plus féconds en biodiversité au monde,
et ce 1,4% de la surface émergée
fournit déjà pour 35%
des services écosystémiques
dont dépendent des gens vulnérables.
Et comme vous pouvez le voir,
l'île Maurice
où je travaille et où je vis
appartient à l'un de ces points de haute biodiversité
et j'étudie les plantes uniques de l'île
pour leur application biomédicale.
Maintenant, revenons en arrière
à la première plante que je vous ai montré
celle, bien sûr, avec les feuilles de différentes formes
et différentes tailles, Terminalia bentzoë,
sous-espèce bentzoë,
une plante que l'on trouve seulement à Maurice.
Alors, la population locale
utilise une décoction des feuilles
contres des maladies infectieuses.
Aujourd'hui notre travail, qui est
la validation scientifique de ces informations traditionnelles,
a montré que justement,
un extrait de la feuille montre une activité, une puissante activité,
contre une large gamme de bactéries
qui pourraient être pathogènes pour l'homme.
Alors, cette plante pourrait-elle être la réponse
à la résistance antibiotique ?
Vous savez, la résistance antibiotique s'avère
un important défi pour le monde.
Même si nous ne sommes pas sûrs de tout, une chose est certaine :
nous ne voulons pas que cette plante disparaisse.
Mais la dure réalité est que
cette plante particulière est, en fait,
considérée comme vulnérable
dans son habitat naturel.
Ce qui m'amène à un autre exemple.
Ce buisson ici est connu comme le baume de l'île Plate
dans le dialecte local.
Le nom botanique est Psiadia arguta.
C'est une plante qui est rare,
qui est endémique à Maurice.
Elle poussait sur le continent autrefois,
mais à cause de la pression de l'urbanisation,
elle a été chassée du continent,
et nous avons réussi à la ramener
du bord de l'extinction
en développant des plantes in vitro
qui poussent maintenant à l'état sauvage.
Alors, je dois vous préciser quelque chose tout de suite,
c'est que, toutes les plantes
ne peuvent pas être développées in vitro.
Pendant que nous, humains, sommes heureux dans notre zone de confort,
ces plantes ont aussi besoin
de leur écosystème pour être préservées.
Et elles ne réagissent pas : les plantes endémiques
ne réagissent pas aux changements intenses de leur écosystème,
et pourtant nous savons quels sont les défis
tels que le changement climatique,
auxquels font face ces plantes.
La population locale utilise aussi ces feuilles
dans la médecine traditionnelle
contre les problèmes respiratoires.
Notre travail de laboratoire préliminaire
sur l'extraction de la feuille a montré que
ces plantes contiennent des ingrédients
qui sont très proches, en termes de structures,
structures chimiques, aux médicaments
qui sont vendus en pharmacie
contre l'asthme.
Alors qui sait
de quoi l'humanité pourrait bénéficier
si cette plante décidait de révéler tous ses secrets.
Je viens d'un monde qui se développe
où nous faisons continuellement face au défi
de l'explosion de la population.
L'Afrique est le continent qui est de plus en plus jeune,
et à chaque fois que l'on parle de l'explosion de la population,
il est question de la sécurité alimentaire
comme étant l'autre face de la même pièce.
Cette plante ici, le baobab,
pourrait faire partie de la réponse.
C'est une plante sous-exploitée, de la nourriture négligée.
Il définit le paysage de l'Afrique de l'Ouest,
où il est connu comme l'Arbre de la Vie,
et plus tard je vous dirai pourquoi
les Africains le considèrent comme l'Arbre de la Vie.
Il y a plusieurs légendes
qui sont associées avec cette plante.
A cause de sa grande taille,
il a été considéré comme régnant sur les plantes inférieures,
alors Dieu n'a pas aimé cette arrogance,
il l'a déraciné, et planté à l'envers,
d'où cette forme particulière.
Et si vous regardez encore cet arbre
dans le contexte africain,
dans l'Afrique de l'Ouest, il est connu comme l'arbre à palabres,
parce qu'il remplit d'importantes fonctions sociales.
Alors si vous aviez un problème dans la communauté,
vous vous réuniriez sous l'arbre à palabres
avec les chefs ou les hommes de la tribu
et ce serait synonyme d'essayer de trouver une solution
à ce problème particulier,
et aussi de renforcer la confiance et le respect
parmi les membres de la communauté.
D'un point de vue scientifique,
il y a huit espèces de baobab dans le monde.
Il y en a une d'Afrique,
une d'Australie,
et six sont endémiques
sur l'île de Madagascar.
Celle que je vous ai montrée
est celle d'Afrique,
Adansonia digitata.
Alors, la fleur, cette belle fleur blanche,
elle s'ouvre la nuit, est pollinisée par les chauves-souris,
et elle donne naissance au fruit
qui est curieusement connue
comme la pomme du singe.
Les singes ne sont pas des animaux stupides.
Ils savent ce qui est bon pour eux.
Si vous ouvrez le fruit du baobab,
vous verrez une pulpe blanche et farineuse,
qui est très riche en nutriments
et qui a des protéines,
plus de protéines que dans le lait humain.
Oui, vous avez bien entendu :
Et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les compagnies alimentaires de ce monde,
recherchent ce fruit pour fournir
ce que nous appelons la nourriture renforcée.
Les graines donnent une huile, une huile très stable
qui est recherchée par l'industrie cosmétique
pour produire des lotions pour le corps, par exemple.
Et si vous regardez le tronc,
le tronc, bien sûr, gardien de l'eau,
qui est souvent récoltée par un voyageur assoiffé,
et les feuilles sont utilisées dans la médecine traditionnelle
contre des maladies infectieuses.
Maintenant vous voyez pourquoi les Africains le considèrent
comme l'Arbre de la Vie.
C'est une plante complète,
et en fait, la haute taille de ces arbres
cache un potentiel immense,
pas seulement pour les industries
pharmaceutique, cosmétique et agroalimentaire.
Ce que je vous ai montré ici
est seulement l'espèce d'Afrique,
Adansonia digitata.
Nous avons encore six espèces au Madagascar,
et nous ne connaissons pas le potentiel de cette plante,
mais une chose que nous savons est que cette flore
est considérée comme menacée d'extinction.
Laissez-moi vous ramener en Afrique,
et vous présenter une de mes préférées,
la plante de la résurrection.
Ici vous trouverez
que même Jésus a de la concurrence.
(Rires)
Cette plante ici a développé
une tolérance remarquable à la sécheresse,
qui lui permet de supporter
une déshydratation jusqu'à 98% pendant une durée de plus d'un an
sans dommages,
et malgré ça, elle peut se régénérer presque complètement
d'un jour sur l'autre, sur 24 heures, et fleurir.
Maintenant, nous, les êtres humains,
nous sommes toujours à la recherche de l'élixir de la jeunesse.
Nous ne voulons pas devenir vieux.
Pourquoi le devrions-nous, surtout si nous pouvons nous le permettre?
Et cela nous donne une indication
de ce à quoique la plante ressemble avant.
Alors, si vous êtes un jardinier inexpérimenté,
la première chose que vous ferez quand vous allez dans le jardin
est de déraciner cette plante parce qu'elle est morte.
Mais si vous l'arrosez, voici ce que vous aurez.
Absolument fantastique.
Alors, si vous regardez notre processus de vieillissement,
le processus de vieillissement est en fait la perte d'eau
de l'épiderme supérieur, dont résultent les rides
que nous connaissons, surtout nous les femmes,
nous en sommes tellement préoccupées.
Et cette plante, en fait, donne aux chimistes des cosmétiques
de très importants ingrédients
qui sont en train de permettre
de ralentir le processus de vieillissement
et en même temps de renforcer nos cellules
contre l'attaque des toxines environnementales.
Maintenant, ces quatre exemples
que je viens de vous donner
sont seulement un infime rappel
sur comment notre santé
et notre survie sont étroitement liées
à la santé et la résistance
de notre écosystème,
et pourquoi nous devrions faire très attention
à préserver la biodiversité.
Chaque fois qu'une forêt est coupée,
chaque fois qu'un marais est asséché,
c'est un laboratoire potentiel qui part avec,
et que nous ne retrouverons plus jamais.
Et je sais de quoi je parle,
venant de l'île Maurice et ayant le dodo qui me manque.
Laissez-moi finir avec un dernier exemple.
Les questions de conservation sont normalement dirigées
vers les plantes rares et endémiques,
mais ce que nous appelons des plantes exotiques,
c'est-à-dire celles qui poussent
dans de nombreux et différents habitats naturels à travers le monde,
elles ont aussi besoin d'être prises en compte.
Vous savez pourquoi ? Parce que l'environnement joue
un rôle très important
dans la modification de la composition de cette plante.
Alors regardons cette plante ici,
Centella asiatica. C'est de la mauvaise herbe.
On l'appelle de la mauvaise herbe.
Alors, Centella asiatica pousse dans le monde entier
dans différents habitats naturels en Afrique, en Asie --
et cette plante a eu un rôle déterminant
pour trouver une solution à une maladie horrible
appelée la lèpre à Madagascar dans les années 1940.
Alors, même si la Centella pousse dans le monde entier
en Afrique, en Asie... La Centella de la meilleure qualité
vient de Madagascar,
parce que cette Centella contient les trois ingrédients vitaux
qui sont recherchés par
les compagnies pharmaceutiques et cosmétiques.
Et les compagnies cosmétiques sont déjà en train de l'utiliser
pour faire de la crème régénératrice.
Alors, il y a un ancien dicton
disant que pour toutes les maladies connues de l'humanité
il y a une plante qui puisse la guérir.
Vous ne croyez peut-être pas aux vieux dictons,
vous pensez peut être qu'ils sont obsolètes
maintenant que notre science et technologie sont si puissantes.
Alors vous regardez peut-être Centella comme étant
une mauvaise herbe, insignifiante et humble,
qui, si détruite, ne manquerait à personne.
Mais vous savez, les mauvaises herbes, ça n'existe pas.
C'est une plante.
C'est un laboratoire biologique vivant
qui pourrait bien avoir les réponses
aux questions que nous pouvons avoir,
mais nous devons nous assurer
qu'elle ait le droit de vivre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)